dumb
no
my hand is you shouldn't have used this
hey guys it's katie and welcome to
another episode of lost in translation
we take a recipe we put it through
google translate it goes from english to
norwegian to danish to lao and many many
many more and finally back to english to
give us a hilariously translated recipe
today's episode i'm very excited about
because we're getting our recipe from a
very special guest hey what's up
everybody i'm so excited to be here
jasmine doesn't know that i'm here yet i
am very excited for the dish that i
chose today i think it might be a little
bit tricky it's based off my friend woon
hangs recipe and i did my own little
twist on it so at the end i'm going to
bring in how the dish is supposed to be
let's see what jasmine does good luck
jasmine rooting for you
[Music]
are you ready yes this one's unique oh
indifferent
vegetable grinder i love it i'm ready to
cook
let's do it let's do it
step one cut eight ounces of i know into
one and a half pieces take it in a bowl
and add plenty of water leave for two
minutes until golden brown
cut eight ounces
of i know
i don't know
[Laughter]
there's bean curd sheets tofu paper
there's some nori more bean curd i
really like the amount of bean curd
sheets we have you do have to soak these
bean curd bean to eye
bean
bean
i'm a human being i that's a stretch
word association power what we're gonna
do is cut eight ounces i guess i have to
weigh them
so i have chosen these i personally have
not worked with them before this is like
asian auntie level i'm not there yet
eight ounces let me grab a bowl first
because i'll have to rehydrate it in
plenty of water one and a half pieces
i'm scared if i cut it now and i need it
big later no good i'll put this here
first i'm just weighing eight ounces so
right now
i am going to just cut all of them in
half i'm gonna fill this with water now
i'm just dousing it making sure it's all
covered in water i guess we're gonna
leave it in for two minutes till they
rehydrate step two rinse the squash on
the skin and inhale a lot of water by
hand transfer to a clean bowl maybe it's
rinse the oil
off the skin and
wring out the excess water i'm just
gonna squeeze this as much as i can to
get all the water out feels so good step
number three in a medium bowl wipe
together the two teaspoon chicken broth
one tablespoon it will work one teaspoon
salt
one teaspoon plums pepper half teaspoon
hungry bite half teaspoon onion flour
three tablespoon of wheat and quarter
cup of water medium bowl is acquired
chicken broth
nutritional yeast oh mushroom powder
when i'm eating this often it is paired
with mushroom powder
yeah for chicken broth i am going with
mushroom bouillon i actually find this
to be a pretty common pairing unless i
got that wrong then i'm i'm
sorry
we still need merch ideas y'all leave it
leave a comment not i'm two teaspoons it
will work something that works yeast
works
it'd be working so i think i'm gonna go
with nutritional yeast one teaspoon salt
i think that's salt that one usually
doesn't change much i think plums pepper
is chili
pepper so i am gonna do one teaspoon of
plums pepper as sichuan chili flakes
half
teaspoon hungry bites i am actually
leaning towards garlic powder that's
what i'm gonna do half teaspoon onion
flour which i think is half teaspoon of
onion powder three tablespoons of wheat
i assume that is flour i will do potato
starch and the quarter cup of water that
i think is water we are going to wipe it
together
smells really good step number four pour
the mixture over the milk skin and mix
divide the tube into five same piece i'm
gonna mix this in here so i don't lose
any mixture so don't mark it wrong alexa
so now we're just gonna mix this i'll
just divide it evenly into five
five i'm gonna do this on a tray divide
the tube into five same piece i think
i'm just gonna divide them equally into
five even though i have more than five
pieces step number five divide the lemon
into five inches
it will require five in total i thought
i already did this
[Laughter]
divide the lemon into five inches it
will require five in
total okay i i will use a hint you get a
special hint
nemo is available on vacation all right
time to call mimo
mimo
help me i'm being bullied
okay i need your help can i read you
this step divide the lemon into five
inches it will require five in total oh
i think i know what that is this lemon
is long good job mimo
thank you mimo that was very helpful
you're welcome good luck thank you bye
she said this lemon is long
i mean this is quite long
this is long too lemon grass
and there's five
oh lemon
oh my god to use the lemongrass what
we're going to do is just use the stalks
yay step number six in a small bowl
combine one and a half tablespoons seal
and one tablespoon of boiled water
divide the soil into perilla leaves
soil something to seal if i'm combining
these somehow i feel like i need some
cornstarch one and a half tablespoon
cornstarch with one tablespoon
room temp water i'm gonna mix this all
together until it dissolves divide the
soil into oh into perilla leaves on this
i think i'm going to brush the soil onto
my gorilla leaf i'm gonna cover this and
i have a lot of slurry left so maybe
that was wrong
step number seven cover the branch
tightly with the marinade to form
compact layers continue wrapping it in
the first layer to get the shape of a
drum
cover the branch tightly branch
tightly with the marinade
marinade okay well then i do have to cut
this into strips
how do i do that now i think i'm gonna
cut these into strips and wrap them
around like a drum and then i'm gonna
take one strip and
cover it tightly with the marinade to
form compact layers there really is no
going back after this so i'm gonna keep
wrapping right now i feel okay i just
hope this is somewhere on the right
track i'm gonna keep doing this and read
step eight katie is so gracious step
number eight bear the ends of a stem to
form a stem
repeat with the remaining stems and
lines
lines i think i'm just gonna continue
doing this until all five are complete
i've finished my first one i'm trying to
make them look a little bit like chicken
drumsticks this will be a while
look at my little soy babies i think
they look pretty cute if i went the
wrong way i'm like wrong wrong wrong
wrong step number nine wrap the exploded
tightly in foil and let cool for 30
minutes so ah
i guess i will wrap these individually
in foil
and then
cool for 30 minutes is fridge for 30
minutes oh freeze
freeze
i'm gonna fry these i can't read ahead
maybe i can no i'll demo you
okay i'm gonna wrap these and then i'm
gonna freeze them it looks like chicken
so cute
these are all wrapped in foil now i'm
gonna put them in the freezer for 30
minutes it could be fridge but i'm gonna
do freezer
brb
step ten there in a bowl one tablespoon
water one tablespoon sitting sauce one
teaspoon
worcestershire and a one teaspoon honey
cart in a bowl it's always my favorite
step there in a bowl sounds so poetic
there
in a bowl i think water's water okay
we'll do one tablespoon water the thing
is i want to say sitting sauce is soy
sauce and i might want to use a hint for
worcestershire because i just don't
think worcestershire is
correct
i think
soy sauce is sitting sauce every time
katie goes
i just feel i'm wrong
so i'll do one tablespoon of sitting
sauce one teaspoon worcestershire i'll
use a hint for worcestershire who would
you like your hand from kelly
is exactly what it tells my hint is you
shouldn't have used this no
now i know for sure
for honey cart i'm gonna do maple syrup
the sauce is beautiful and amber colored
step 11 take the circuit board out of
the fridge and remove the plastic screw
cover with sauce and set aside i must
head to the freezer this is my circuit
board remove the plastic screw which is
the foil oh that was good
there my plastic screws are here cover
with sauce and set aside so what i'm
gonna do is take the sauce that i just
made and just coat them all the only
reason i feel more confident is because
we are working with ingredients i'm
familiar with but who knows did i just
gravitate towards the one that i'm from
you know it's like the outside is gonna
be well coated i'm not sure how deep
it's gonna seep in step number 12 do a
true
325 degree evolution spin
i think i will have to do
either bring oil to 325 degrees or
preheat the oven to 325.
um i think do a true 325 degree
evolution means to
preheat the oven to 325. i will be right
back step 13 add the drums and sprinkle
with a non-stick stick boil what for
eight to ten minutes until crispy golden
brown
the cooking method is
very important may i have a hint would
you use non-stick stick
to fry
wait wait wait wait i use it for my air
free air
can you get out of your golem-like
position
i want a new hint is it air fryer
you don't get a new hint that's your
hand
dang so it's oven
i am going to sprinkle with my nonstick
stick boil for eight to ten minutes
until crispy golden brown i think means
to put it in the oven for eight to ten
minutes i will be right back step 14
half cup of sauce in a medium saucepan
mix two tablespoons of honey with half
teaspoon of sesame and salt are
delicious we got a hot plate and now i
need a medium saucepan half cup of sauce
what kind
half cup of sugar i think it's brown
sugar or is it water
no
four
three
two
one
zero
i freeze under pressure i'm gonna do
half a cup of sugar two tablespoons of
honey as soy sauce because you want to
you have a lot of questions
half teaspoon of sesame and salt half a
teaspoon of sesame oil salt it could be
some salt do you think that was right
yeah
final step fill the fried tannin with
honey grilled sauce and garnish with
vegetables good father
fill the fried tannin with honey grilled
sauce i think that is use the sauce and
coat it on my plastic screws now we are
going to fill the fried tannins with my
honey grilled sauce i just don't know
what i would garnish with garnish with
some
sesame seeds before i garnish i am going
to transfer my fried tannins onto my
plate to garnish i am just gonna cover
it with a little bit of toasted sesame
seeds because sesame seeds are
vegetables
there we have it vegetable grinder so
you ready to meet the guests and see
what they're supposed to look like
oh my gosh
i'm honored to be here i'm very excited
so i see what you've done here based off
my recipe yours is beautiful honestly
yours is giving me like croissant vibes
i'm like this looks decadent the recipe
i chose is vegan chicken wings using
yuba or tofu skin well i have made
vegetable grinder
do you want to try vegetable grinder so
badly you have no idea all right cheers
cheers
mmm
that's good that's really good is it
mmm i like it it's got a nice meaty chew
to it which is kind of like the heart of
this recipe in the first place a little
salty i'm not above that though what i'm
really impressed is that you nailed the
layers so great job okay i want to try
yours let's do it cheers
mmm
this tastes like barbecue drumsticks how
did you get from honey to mushrooms
things happen tomorrow okay i think you
did a really good job they're related
they're like cousins well this was a lot
of fun merle thank you so much for this
recipe you're welcome i honestly thought
it was going to trip you up more than it
did i feel like you absolutely nailed it
i do feel like i have a confidence boost
make sure to tune in next week because
uh i think i needed this confidence
boost that's all i'll say we will see
you next week bye bye
this is gonna be a fun one
she's gonna cry no you're so much taller
hold on i know
oh the double stone hungry by a baby
hungry bite put that on a shirt put that
on a shirt so you want any merchandise
i won't accept bribes only bribes from
josh vegetable grinder that's going to
be my new nightclub
or an app for
just dating for vegans professional
grinder
[Music]